what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the banner of war and its
conclusion now a lot of you guys have
asked the question where is this story
how come we haven't finished it yet and
that's because marvel pushed it all the
way back to coincide with the release of
she-hulk so make of that what you will
but what we end up doing here is picking
up with this kind of final conflict
right this final battle between thor and
hulk and what donny kates does is he
actually turns basically everything we
know about thor completely and totally
on its head the watchers here of course
because it's a massive calamity kind of
an observable event but it's one of
these things where sort of the answer to
the question what will happen when the
incredible hulk and thor fight to the
death now one of the things that we have
to bear in mind here is that the tables
have kind of turned to a degree that
because of all the energy the kind of
gamma bomb that the incredible hulk had
basically let off that it essentially
turned thor into a gamma irradiated
version of himself and then of course
odin granted uh the incredible hulk the
ability to lift mjolnir so basically the
roles are flipped that the incredible
hulk has become thor and thor has become
the hulk but the thing about this is
that what you have while this whole
conflict is going on you have odin who's
actually talking directly to banner
himself and literally saying okay you
have to pull out all the stops here and
one of the things that happens is you
have odin that says like we have to find
a way to get him like to get him out of
this place we have to find a way to get
this guy defeated but the issue of of
really from hulk's perspective is the
bifrost is gone thor destroyed the
bifrost in its hulk form so the question
is if the bifrost is gone how in the
world do they teleport him out of there
like if we have to try to get him to
asgard how can we do that and the
response of odin this is really kind of
a funny thing the response of odin is
that's because you're only looking at
mjolnir in the way in which thor ever
used it which was as a hammer he just
hit things with it but the power of
mjolnir stretches far beyond anything
that thor has used it for remember the
hammer is empowered by a god at first it
was the the tempest storm right the god
tempest literally a cosmic entity that
odin confined to the inside of the
hammer using magic as well as basically
smithing that was done by the dwarves
the other part of this is that once the
god tempest was basically defeated and
the hammer was destroyed when it was
recreated it was imbued with the power
of odin and that's what he's referring
to it's empowered by me and my powers
are almost limitless so sure we can't
necessarily take him like we can't take
him to asgard using the bifrost bridge
but the bifrost bridge is not the only
way in and out of asgard and so while
this is all going on you have this
portal that's opened up using the hammer
that sends the two of them to asgard
proper and when they arrive there you've
literally got all these asgardians who
are watching this fight unfold and the
question that's being asked by sif is
with everything going on here and the
incredible hulk having mjolnir even
without it the incredible hulk could
literally crush thor right like thor has
barely ever beaten hulk in the past and
the response of bill is that's not true
the hulk has never actually fought thor
not the real thor and this is vader ray
bill or at least donnie kate's by way of
beta ray bill turning it all on its head
that what donny cates basically tells us
here is that in the past when thor and
the hulk have fought that hulk faced the
avenger right the humble and noble thor
but do not forget there was a reason
thor was cast down to midgard to learn
humility to learn honor to learn to
wield his power with mercy but now hulk
faces not just the mirror of his own
rage but a rage that has been held back
for hundreds of years a power this world
has never seen in the past when they've
clashed thor believed truly in his heart
that somewhere inside of the hulk there
was a man an ally a warrior worthy of
forgiveness of mercy but now if thor is
truly unleashed if he sees no man inside
of that beast hulk will finally learn
what it is to fight a god and that's the
difference here that's what donnie
kate's is really telling us here and in
all honesty it fits right it really fits
into the thor mythos there's been
precious few times when we've actually
seen thor just unleash himself and the
only times we've ever really seen that
is when he enters the warriors madness
and he's usually brought down in some
capacity back to his normal self what
this story gives us is literally this
just unleashed version of thor this
version of himself that's not holding
back in any capacity and it's really
really amazing to see donald kids kind
of look at this and say this is what the
actual strength of thor looks like do
not have any illusions the incredible
hulk is very very strong the incredible
hulk is very very capable but against a
god like thor who has routinely held
back the incredible hulk doesn't have
anything on the sky now there are also
caveats and that's one of the things to
remember here thor is fighting hard and
fast and the reason for that is the
longer the battle goes on the angrier
the incredible hulk's gonna get and the
stronger he gets donnie kate's not
ignoring that caveat he's not blowing
that off and saying well no no the
incredible hulk strength is finite
thor's just that much further along than
him it's simply just at this point in
time as powerful as the incredible hulk
is that thor is that much further beyond
him the other thing and this is one of
the genius maneuvers by donnie cates
it's not just the incredible hulk
running rampant with just unbridled rage
that keeps increasing over time that one
of the things that bruce banner had done
was that in order to weaponize the
incredible hulk and to use him as a kind
of controllable object he basically
implanted in him safeguards right the
the the incredible hulk strength cannot
reach an unlimited level unless banner
allows it to right by controlling that
device that increases right increases
the various conflicts and so on and so
forth the things that we've covered over
the course that which is why i say you
should definitely go back and watch our
coverage we'll have a playlist down in
the description so you can get caught up
for those of you guys who are new to all
this so you're not feeling left out like
what the heck is going on here but
basically there is a kind of temporary
cap a temporary limit to how strong the
incredible hull can get now the question
that would have to be asked here and
this is the question that's not really
being asked and i really hope that
donnie kate asks it over the course of
his run the question to ask here is what
happens when the incredible hulk fights
thor and it's like heart of the monster
hulk or like world breaker hulk like the
most powerful version of the hulk that
we've seen because while this version of
hulk is strong he's not world breaker
he's not like he's not like the world
war hulk version of himself he's not up
there with like heart of the monster
hook but thor is incredibly strong hence
the reason why he's able to overpower
him in this way and why hulk needs
mjolnir to come out on top so what they
end up doing here is they come up with a
plan they say okay what we have to do
here is we basically have to push thor
into the world tree because by pushing
him into the world tree we can basically
channel the energies of all the nine
realms basically the power of the
universe itself into containing and
controlling him and where hulk does that
and knocks him into the world tree the
world tree starts to basically encase
thor but it doesn't work he actually
starts to rip out of it and this is one
of the things what odin says here is he
says for thor right now we are using the
united power of every realm in the known
and unknown universe to cage his madness
all of the voices of the elders
whispering to him guiding him back to
the god that he is literally trying to
talk since into him all of the magics
and enchantments known to the runes and
fates to leech this fury from his soul
all of this and i don't think it's
enough now there are things we can infer
here right there are things that we can
draw on here for example when thor used
the powers of the runes during the old
thor disassembled story and destroyed
the ones who sit above in shadow he
became rune king thor that the powers of
the runes are not enough to contain him
in this hulk form with this unbridled
rage so you could probably make a
credible argument that this version of
thor is beyond rune king thor now i'm
not gonna say that with any real
certainty there's nothing to really
indicate here that's the case it's quite
literally us just sort of looking at the
evidence and to a degree cooking the
books that's kind of what it is
but regardless of whether or not you see
him on that level of power he still
achieves a monumental feat which is the
exact same thing that rune king thor did
in the sense that he destroys the world
tree now the difference is that instead
of using mjolnir to smash the tree to
bits he actually rips it out of the
ground like he rips the world tree out
of the ground now one thing to
understand and this is a testament to
just how powerful this version of thor
is the
world tree is anchored to realities it's
anchored to entire dimensions right
we're talking about an object here that
literally holds sway across pretty much
the universe itself so it's almost like
thor ripping out a portion of the
universe it's crazy and that's when like
odin and and like bruce banner are
watching this and it's like how the hell
do we beat that how do we beat a guy who
can basically rip a hole in the universe
how do we how do we face off against
something like this and the response of
of banner is it might be that it's not
even one of these things where we fight
we can't stop this through physical
force we can just keep fighting and
fighting and fighting but the reality is
it would probably lead to the end of
reality as we know it the only way to do
this is to actually talk to him and
that's what odin does now initially this
kind of seems to kind of fall flat but
this what donnie kate's is doing here in
terms of like thor and odin is actually
years in the making because one of the
things that's always been a hallmark of
the character of thor is the grudge he
holds to his father and to a degree the
grudge that odin holds towards thor that
the two of them never quite saw eye to
eye and they were as much enemies in a
lot of instances as they were father and
son with a familial relationship what
donny cates has been working on here
over the course of his run and even to a
degree what was happening in the run
before his in jason aaron's run is you
were basically talking about odin sort
of changing things up a bit and being
more of a father to thor than he had
ever really been before and that's what
he tells him he was like it's me like
i'm currently in possession of the
hulk's body it's me that you're talking
to it's odin and he literally apologizes
to him and he says i'm sorry my son not
only for the many troubles but for what
i have done as well i know that i have
not always been kind to you i have made
many mistakes too many but through it
all despite my failures despite our
differences i must remind you i still
love you son and where it begins to kind
of talk down thor to a degree the
response of odin is if you would my boy
allow me to do what all fathers are
called to do for their sons help them
with their burdens and this is a hugely
significant moment here but it's like
the fight between dr doom and reed
richards at the end of secret wars it's
only important if you understand the
history between the characters if you
don't really know much about the history
between uh odin and thor the moment's
entirely lost on you and it looks like
donnie cage is just taking the lazy way
out in a story but looking at it for
what it is and knowing the history
between the two that odin has always
been cold and hard towards thor that he
wasn't really much of a father figure to
him and so what this does is it's almost
kind of donnie kate's transposing the
real life circumstances that we endure
right sons that argue with their fathers
fathers that argue with their sons
fathers and sons that can't quite see
eye to eye that have these huge rifts
and it's odin and thor mending the rift
between the two of them what this does
is it allows odin to use the odin force
to basically burn the gamma radiation
out of thor and then because the odin
force is effectively limitless it allows
him to restore the world tree of
idrissil now that's one of the things to
know a lot of times people are kind of
like i mean this kind of seems like a
caveat but not really right it's always
happened that way that's how thor was
able to restore uh asgard during j
michael strzenski's run is how he was
able to find the various asgardians that
had been confined to human form and
restore them so it's one of those things
where it's kind of you're kind of
forgetting the history of how the odin
force works and then in turn getting
pissed off about it right like it's it's
the open force has always been this way
and so it's cool to see it happen
because what goes on here is that
following thor basically returning back
to being the all father the gamma
radiation being removed from him that
there is a kind of temporary truce that
struck between the two where thor
actually allows the incredible hulk to
leave and so when iron man wakes up and
it's like god i can't believe it right
like that whole thing knocked me out
what happened to the hulk the response
of uh of thor is i mean just the the
power of the explosion man it basically
eradicated everything that was uh that
was mortal you know he literally says it
was all for too much to withstand except
for a god right so basically nobody
survived and that is kind of allowed the
hulk to leave and to effectively
disappear now tony stark could quite
easily put together i mean thor you know
the incredible hulk's probably still
alive but he just sort of lets it slide
but he just sort of lets it kind of go
away but he also sort of plays into it
saying like i can't believe that like
he's gone right and the response of thor
is well i think that in some way banner
let himself be destroyed he simply just
wanted to be free and iron man's like
well i want to go home and that's
basically it the reality here is that if
iron man truly believed that banner and
the incredible hulk were dead his
reaction would have been a lot more
significant than damn i can't believe it
that's crazy you know it would have been
much more it would have been much larger
than that like i mean it would have been
a pretty big deal like it's a pretty
huge thing but regardless of course this
basically sees what is to a degree uh
everybody just kind of going back to
some measure of normalcy but for the
incredible hulk himself the cool thing
about this is the story continues on
that banner jumps right back into the
bleed which is the space between
universes and right back into the
multiverse again where his journey takes
him i have no earthly clue but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace